Viruses is perhaps the best
known type of malware.
A virus infects a program,
by modifying the program code so
that when a program runs,
the virus code also runs.
It then self-copy into other programs,
and thus, spreads itself.
There are many four stages in
the life cycle of a virus.
The first is a dormant phase.
This is the phase when a program has
just been infected by a virus but
program has not run yet so the virus
has not been triggered or spread.
The second stage is propagation.
This is when the malware's
being sent around or spread.
For example, the malware can
come as an email attachment and
the email attachment is
being sent to many users.
The third phase is the triggering phase.
This is when the host
program is being run.
And as a result,
the virus is also triggered to run.
For example, when a user clicks an email
attachment that contains a virus,
it's triggering
the virus to run as well.
The fourth stage is the execution phase.
This is when the virus code runs,
performs some malicious activities, and
most importantly, it looks for
targets to infect so that it can spread.
For example,
in a case of email attachment,
when the virus runs it can search for
users in the address book, and
then send email attachment with
the virus to users in the address book.
And that's how he can be propagated,
triggered, executed, and
again propagated,
triggered, and executed.
And this is how virus spreads